hello everybody just before we get
started into this one today I do want to
say there are a lot of Japanese words if
I scrub the pronunciations I did my best
have a go at me in the comments below if
you want that spot there for Miyamoto
Musashi was the greatest swordsman who
ever come out of a nation of great
swordsman now of course in Japan
his story which has become the basis for
countless flying swordsman oriental
movies is one of raw courage unbridled
ambition and unparalleled mindfulness in
one-on-one combat he defeated sixty
opponents yet his greatest legacy is his
seminal work the book of five rings
which is still pored over by military
tactician z' and mindfulness enthusiasts
450 years after it was written in this
week's biographic Sui reveal the man
that was Musashi
there is much uncertainty over the
details and dates pertaining to the life
of Musashi
what follows is based primarily on his
own account as recorded in the book of
five rings Miyamoto Musashi was born in
the spring of 1584 in the village of
Miyamoto in the Ishino districts of the
new Misaka province in Japan he was born
into nobility with his mother who died
giving birth to him being the daughter
of a minor local chief tang
his father mooney was a warrior in the
shinmin clan who had become an expert in
the fighting arts he was especially
adept at jiu-jitsu swordsmanship and the
use of the guitar an iron rod with fork
like protrusions when he was in his 30s
mone had been invited to the capital of
Kyoto to deal with another highly
regarded warrior in the presence of the
Shogun Mooney beat the man in two out of
three bouts the victory established
musashi's father as he whole show which
means without equal in Japan really was
intent on teaching his son everything
that he knew about the fighting arts
although Musashi was a quick learner
he had a stubborn streak that saw him
constantly clashing with his father
while everyone else treated me with the
utmost respect and reverence Musashi
would often talk back and criticize his
father this resulted in a volatile
relationship which often culminated in
violence on one occasion Mooney took a
knife and threw it at his son Musashi
managed you dodged the weapon which
buried itself in the wall beside him but
the father's anger it was not over he
threw the seven-year-old boy out of the
house essentially disowning him Musashi
crossed the commissar pass to the
province of harima where he travelled to
the small village of hero fuckin here he
was taken in by his uncle to Rin durin
has once been a warrior but he and long
ago renounced the fighting arts becoming
a Buddhist monk and living a life of
study and meditation he raised Musashi
at his small Buddhist temple sat on the
edge of the village here the boy learns
to read and to write as well as to
meditate and develop his spirituality
musashi's real passion however lay with
the martial arts he spent countless
hours alone in the woods sparring
against the unforgiving trunks of pine
trees his anger at his father being
released as he built upon the skills
that had been instilled by that great
warrior in his work the book of five
rings Musashi recorded that his first
real fight occurred when he was 13 years
of age he related that a passing warrior
by the name of Hari McKee hai had put a
sign up along the saya River challenging
any local swordsman to a duel the bolds
and impetus Musashi took up the
challenge writing his name of the sign
ki hai considered the challenge a joke
but accepted it anyway intent on
teaching the young upstart a lesson
musashi's uncle Doran was shocked when
he heard what his nephew had done on the
day of the challenge he went ahead of
the boy and attempted to beg it off
while he was pleading with ki hai
Musashi charged his opponents with a
six-foot quarter staff he caught ki high
off guard dubbing him to the ground and
then striking him between the eyes with
a succession of blows he then beat him
to death three years later Musashi left
here at fuku and set off to make his way
in the world he traveled along the Sanyo
Doge the old high road skirting the
northern shore of the Inland Sea to the
Straits of Shimonoseki from there he
ferried across the waters to the port of
Kokura and then on to nakatsu this was
the castle town where his father now
lived Rudy had entered into the service
of Yoshitaka the master of nakatsu
castle the teenager arrived to find his
father's army were in the midst of a
campaign to subdue the islands of Kishu
and waged war on the western provinces
Musashi was recruited into the force and
soon found himself fighting alongside
his father it was his first taste of war
the campaign proved to be a great
success with two provinces being brought
under the Dominion of Yeshe taka
following the campaign Musashi's aging
father retired from active duty moving
to the nearby port of Katsuki yes
as the father exited from the world of
mortal combat of the Sun he was just
getting started that campaign
it had whet his appetite and he was
eager for more in terms on becoming a
great warrior or swordsman like his
father he set out a path forward he
needed to perfects the art of
swordsmanship seek out and defeat other
masters and then found his own school of
swordsmanship
never one to think small Musashi
set his sights on the most prestigious
school of swordsmanship in the realm the
famous Yoshioka clan in Kyoto he knew
that if he could fully defeat even one
member of this plan he would put himself
on the fast-track to recognition as a
master swordsman so without saying a
word to his father he rose early one
morning collected his few belongings and
set out to claim his destiny he bartered
his way onto a small merchant vessel to
the port of ceccacci from there he set
out on foot to Kyoto and sort out the
Yoshioka clan he threw down his
challenge which was easily accepted by
their top swordsman seijuro the duel
would take place on the grounds of the
rend I temple when he arrived at the
venue Musashi lapped upon his opponent
without warning just as he had done in
his first duel and felled siguro
with a single blow from his Bok toe the
fight was over before it even properly
began the shock defeat of the top
swordsman rot the Yoshioka clan Seguros
brother Dan Shapiro was incensed at the
manner in which the young upstart from
the south had attacked his brother when
he was unprepared he challenged Musashi
to a second challenge on the very spot
where the first had occurred this time
it was the Yoshioka swordsmen who
charged first attempting to strike a
fatal blow with his five foot Bock tone
but Musashi managed to wrestle the
weapon away from densha cheering using
it to beat his opponent to death the
Yoshioka had now been bested twice in
short order and this was too much for
their honour to bear they decided that
Musashi had to be killed they devised
the plan to ambush him in the woods
outside of the hostel where he was
staying more than a hundred Yoshioka
students armed with sticks bows and
arrows gathered under the leadership of
densha Kira's son his name was mater
Shuchi room and he came up against
Musashi unperturbed Musashi rushed
straight for mater chateroo killing him
in front of the others
overawed the Yoshioka fell back allowing
Musashi to slip away
having established his supremacy by
decimating the most highly respected
warrior clan in the land
Musashi returns to Kyoto in the space of
a few days he had brought down a school
of swordsmanship that had reigned
supreme for over a century still he knew
that he had a lot to learn in order to
become the greatest warrior in the
nation from Kyoto he traveled to the
temple of Nara here he found a line of
warrior monks who were experts in hoser
endure the art of fighting with the
lance the temple master was fascinated
with Musashi's ability to fight with two
swords at once
quinta jesters finest student against
the newcomer he arranged for two bouts
with a monk named aku xoan in neither of
these fights was the Lancer able to gain
the other hand over Musashi leaving Nara
and the Saar she traveled to Edo city
that was teeming with accomplished
swordsmen many of these swordsmen had
forged their talents on the field of
battle here Musashi opened his own dojo
one of hundreds in the city news quickly
spread of his unique style and he soon
was being flooded with students one of
them was Mizuno cats Inari a well
respected and battle-hardened warrior
the fame of Musashi's dojo it's spread
reaching all the way to Edo castle and
the Shogun himself he was invited to
teach there but declined when he
realized that he would be subject to a
member of the hated yangu clan after
teaching in Edo for seven years Musashi
decided to return to Kazuki the town of
his father the aging mooney had set up
his own dojo and was eager to pass it on
to his son before he arrived back in
Katsuki however Musashi wants to fight
one more Challenger his journey home
brought him to the small islands of fun
Ashima in the straits of shimonoseki
it was here that he was challenged by a
famed warrior by the name of Sasaki
Kojiro this was a man so fierce that he
had earned the moniker demon of the
western provinces he was a master of
Nadar Chi the great Japanese sword
legend tells us that Musashi's only
weapon was a bokken or a wooden sword
that he had carved from an ore of the
boat that had brought him to the island
with this he managed to subdue and kill
Sasaki without immediately jumped into
his boat and rowed out to sea in order
to get away from Sasaki's enraged
followers
musashi now completed his journey to
KITT suku where he began teaching at his
father's dojo for three years he lived
and worked in the small seaside village
during this time his fractured
relationship with his father got my
better with the old man criticizing his
son's martial ability at every
opportunity
when Mooney died at the age of 85
Musashi was more relieved than saddened
shortly after his father's passing
Musashi received a letter from his
former students Mizzou new cats Inari
war had broken out between the great
clans of Tokugawa Ren's Toyotomi cats
Inari was about to take part in the
seams on the Tokugawa side along with
his eldest son who was just 16 years old
cats Inari requested that Musashi serve
as part of a special escort of 10
mounted warriors for his son for 30 year
olds Musashi saw this as his opportunity
to jump back into the thick of combat he
set off from Kazuki to the port of
ceccacci he was determined to be the
protector in battle of the young son of
his beloved students he met up with
Captain Ari's forces riding at the head
of 4,000 men as they advanced on a Sokka
and then on to Kaka boom a Hamlet's made
up of a few farms stretching along the
southern bank of the Yamamoto River just
a few miles downstream a large enemy
force and gathered the night however
Katzen Ari's army managed to surrounds
the Toyotomi forces the attack was
ordered at 10 p.m. the hour of the snake
and the Toyotomi were sent reeling they
fled across the issue River only to be
chased down by cats Inari's men Musashi
was in the lead wielding his favorite
weapon the Bakht our records tell us
that he stood on the heights of a bridge
sending one enemy warrior after another
flying with the deadly blows of his
trusty pocket all the Osaka winter and
summer campaigns in which the Tokugawa
were victorious but an end to the
resistance of Japan's Western warlords
the culmination of the hostilities was
the siege of Osaka Castle it was the
largest battle in which Musashi
would ever take part with many thousands
of warriors being slaughtered on both
sides
among those of his comrades to fall was
Nakagawa a mana Sookie who was stricken
down as cats Inari's men had stormed the
southern gate of the castle
the man had three sons who traveled with
the army the two older boys took part in
the siege but the youngest was just 11
with the death of his father the young
man now needed a guardian
musashi took the boy minica tsuki under
his wing adopting him as his son and set
off of castle town of ma from there they
want Santi here a fuku where his
stepmother lived for the next two years
he lived here caring for his elderly
stepmother while also providing for his
new son many hours each day was spent in
parting to Miki misuki the fighting
skills that he himself had learned as a
young boy from his own father this
tranquil existence was interrupted when
news reached the village of horrific ooh
that akedan would samatha the current
Lord if him a castle was going to move
the new Lord was going to be Honda Tata
MRSA Musashi saw this change in
leadership as an opportunity for his
adopted son during the storming of a
Sarka castle tada masa had been in
command of the second eastern phalanx
directly behind the troops of Captain re
where Musashi was stationed he has
therefore seen Musashi in action in the
heat of battle Musashi requested that
his son mid samatha be given duty in the
Lord's household tada masa agrees and
the boy was made a page to his own son
tada Toki
at the same time Musashi was hired by
the neighboring daimyo Nargis our Tara's
Anya he was appointed as an adviser to
the magistrate in charge of the
construction of a huge building project
the construction of Akashi Castle this
was followed by the planning of the town
of him a massage she was also in charge
of the castle gardens and oversaw the
construction of a tea house miniature
mountains and a miniature lake he proved
to have a meticulous eye for detail and
was obsessive in getting every tree
shrub and stone placed just right the
years that he spent at Akashi were the
happiest of Musashi's life as well as
planning out the landscaping and tending
to the gardens he instructed his
retainers in the art of fighting with
two swords he also enjoyed hearing of
these successes of his son who grew in
favour in the house of tada masa
in the spring of 16 26 Lords tada toki
was struck down with tuberculosis being
forced to keep his quarters at ma castle
after a three-month struggle with the
disease he died at only 30 Musashi knew
all too well what this meant for his son
as the key retainer of the stricken Lord
Makino Suki was customarily bounced to
commit seppuku a ritual suicide by
disembowelment Makino Sookie's death
left a deep emotional scar on Musashi
from which he would never fully recover
for months he shunned all company
retreating to the forest to commune with
nature and tried to come to terms with
his great loss almost exactly a year
after Makino Suki's death Musashi
adopted a second son a boy named Laurie
who was the second son of tomorrow is
submit soon a samurai in the service of
the lord of miki castle when their
castle had been overthrown by the
Tokugawa army hit submit sue took up the
life of a poor farmer when he died his
youngest son Laurie became an orphan
Musashi took him in and arranged for him
to enter the service of Lord Tallis Anya
the boy would eventually attain the rank
of senior retainer stations on the
southern island of Kyushu Musashi moved
there to be closer to the boy and spent
the last twenty years of his life on the
island Musashi built a large dojo on the
islands and soon had a huge following
all agur to learn from the great master
even though located on a remote islands
far from the main centers many martial
arts masters visited his dojo to
experience the art of fighting with two
swords the aging Musashi was respected
and admired as a great martial arts
grandmaster still he was as he had
always been an outsider he did not groom
himself as was expected
he left his hair grown long and unkempt
he also seldom bathed and refused to
wear the traditional attire of a
swordsman of that time in his waning
years even abandoned his two swords
preferring to carry and use nothing more
than a five-foot wooden staff in early
at 1638 an armed revolt broke out in the
province of his honor the rebellion was
made up of Christians led by
seventeen-year-old Amakusa Shiro they
numbered more than 20,000 men there
discussed themselves the long abandoned
her a castle
Lord haleh's Anya the employer of
musashi's adopted son engaged the aging
master to escort his 23-year old son to
the battlefield along with 8,000 men
Musashi
stayed at the boys side throughout the
entire siege when the defenders in
sign the castle threw boulders down from
the walls he lept in front of the Lord
source and fended them off with his
staff Musashi hadn't been back from the
rebellion for long when he was
approached to take up a position in the
household of the daimyo of one of the
largest thief's in the country
this was hosokawa territory he wanted
Musashi to relocate to come Emoto and
instruct his retainers in the art of
fighting with two swords the swordsmen
accepted arriving in Kumamoto in
September of 1640 he was given a
comfortable mansion on the north eastern
side of the castle grounds Musashi took
to spending much time in the mountains
of avato where he would wile away the
hours in meditation and contemplation he
found the cave which afforded him
perfect solitude it was here that he
began to put his thoughts to paper in
the early spring of 1645 he completed
the first draft of the work that would
make him immortal down through the ages
the Goron no shawl or book of five rings
the book had taken five seasons to
complete each one seeing the completion
of one long scroll he named them for
Scrolls of a fire water winds in heaven
shortly after the completion of his
great work massages health took a sudden
turn for the worse within a month he was
no longer able to teach he withdrew to
his house outside the castle walls
feeling his life ebbing away he summoned
his chief retainer and handed him the
Goron no shown having passed on his
legacy he then closed his eyes and
allowed the life to drain from his body
it was June the 13th 1645 shortly after
his death a stone memorial to be known
as mount Musashi was erected not far
from his home in Kaido four centuries
thereafter passers-by would dismount
from their horses to pay homage to the
greatest swordsman the Japan would ever
produce so I really hope you found that
video interesting if you did please do
hit that thumbs up button below and do
not forget to subscribe for brand new
videos just like this every Monday and
Thursday also check out some of our
videos from the archive they're over
there on the right if you enjoyed this
video you'll enjoy some of those and as
always thank you for watching